hi there Steve Kaufman here today and
I'm gonna talk about learning multiple
languages at the same time this is in
response to a question I received from
one of my viewers here he asked whether
I would recommend he was I thinks he's
from Sweden Pele if I remember correctly
he's studying Russian hasn't been added
very long but would also like to start
studying German and what do I think I am
asked this question regularly what do I
think well I have a number of thoughts
on the subject first of all that a
person who is learning one language
wants to learn another language or even
a third language is something that I
fully understand and fully endorse once
we discover the pleasure of learning a
language of discovering a language even
before we're able to speak it the
pleasure of exploring a new world of
different culture different history
different ways of expressing things it
is very very rewarding and chanting
pleasurable and so now we want to
explore some other language and it is
true that once we have mastered or
become relatively good at communicating
in a new language we feel more confident
and we're better able then to learn a
third and a fourth and a fifth language
so the fact that in fact you know I
guess in Europe it's more common that
people speak two or three or four
languages because there's so many
different languages in Europe in a
relatively limited area it's far less
common in North America if I take the
example of Canada kids who study French
in school mostly they don't end up
speaking French so even learning one
language is a major obstacle achievement
I mean all kinds of people I meet here
in Vancouver who say while Steve you
speak all those languages I would love
to learn French or Spanish or something
course they don't do much about it or
they might have taken a course and have
given up so here in North America
we have all kinds of people who can even
speak one foreign language but in Europe
you know speaking several languages is
quite con I don't think it takes any
special talent to learn multiple
languages I mean some people may do
better than others but everyone can do
it
some may pronounce better some may have
larger vocabularies different people
have different interests but everyone is
capable of doing it and it's a rewarding
thing to do for everyone so I encourage
it I've often said that the way you know
French is taught here in Canada makes no
sense because we're teaching people kids
how to say certain basic things in
French hopefully correctly when in fact
the kids know that they would probably
never have a chance to use French and
certainly not in those specific
scenarios that they like to teach in
school I've often felt that a language
instruction in our school should be more
a matter of discovery learning to
understand building up vocabulary
exploring languages even more than one
language so exploring languages even
it's only if it's only sort of passively
in order to understand the language and
understand more about the countries to
learn about the countries through the
language learn about their history and
culture all that stuff is great multiple
languages great that's part one of my
answer part two of my answer is while I
know that there are some polyglots I've
seen their videos who can study two
three four or five languages
simultaneously I can't
so that suggests that there are some
people who can and some people who can
or I shouldn't say that I can't but I
prefer not to so some people like doing
it and others don't I prefer to
concentrate on one language because I
find it so absorbing studying one
language it ties me up and commit I just
can't get enough of the language and I
know from experience that the more
intensive the more might be the greater
degree of concentration on that language
the better I will do in other words I
spent five years learning Russian an
hour a day I spent nine months learning
Chinese seven hours a day I did a better
job on Chinese the more intensive the
experience the better you're going to
learn the more often you're going to
meet the same words again that the more
your brain is going to get into that
greater you know a heat of intensity
that is helping the brain absorb the new
language so my preference is always for
a high degree of concentration I also
like to explore so I'd link I'll go and
have a look at Dutch and discover that I
can decipher quite a few of the lessons
and the Dutch lessons or polish which is
a little similar to check so I'll do a
little bit of exploring but I won't
spend much time because learning another
language is a lot of work so it's one
thing to go and explore I've explored
Arabic I scored Turkish all at length
but I know that if I were to engage in
in committing myself to learn any of
those languages it would be a lot of
work a full-time job you can't have two
full-time jobs so if my full-time job is
check the Czech language then I can be
totally on to check
I might have 20% to spend on languages
that I already speak to a fairly good
level so with my check I would
occasionally listen to Russian so that
you know I could maintain my Russian
because as I say it even when I went to
learn Portuguese even though I spoke
Spanish and the vocabulary is 95% or
whatever 90 85 percent the same it
wasn't as easy as I thought it was
difficult because it's not you know and
I bought a book for example how Spanish
words convert into Portuguese well it's
not a matter of reading a list here in
this Spanish where it becomes this in
Portuguese you forget it no longer no
sooner have you gone through the list
that you've forgotten it you have to
create habits in the brain and to create
these habits the greater the intensity
of the of the exposure of the workout in
my view the sooner you're going to get a
real good control of that language even
for relatively similar languages like
Spanish and Portuguese not to mention
difficult languages or languages that
are quite different from each other like
Russian and German so but what you can
do is you can focus on one language for
six months maybe 80% and then 20%
exploring the other language then you
can turn it around and go 80% on
language to say German in the case of
our friend from Sweden and then just
little 20% on Russian and you can
flip-flop back and forth if you want I
tend to get totally absorbed but if I
look back at sort of some situations
that have occurred to me
I spend a year on Czech leading up to
going to prom and of course eventually
to be good at the language you have to
speak a lot you build up your potential
through a lot of intensive listening and
reading you build up your familiarity
with the language you build up your
vocabulary you're not too concerned
about grammar although you refer to it
from time to time because it helps you
notice things and then you have to start
speaking and when you speak not only do
improve your ability to speak but you'll
also improve your ability to notice
because you remember and you notice
those things that you weren't able to do
when you were speed and so you step up
you're speaking so it's all intense work
and in my case with Czech and led up to
me going to the Czech Republic and I
spent five days there in Prague speaking
seven eight hours of the object a day
and I was very happy with what I had
achieved then I said if you're not going
to work on Korean so I worked on Korean
for four or five months not quite as
intensely and then I had a business trip
to Romania so I spent two we and months
working on Romania and I got the
Romanian up to a level where I could
kind of communicate and speak and talk
about a variety of subjects and
understand newscasts and so forth bear
in mind of Romanians seventy percent
similar vocabulary to Italian and when I
was in the midst of talking to all these
Romanians there was a fellow there who
was Czech and so I wanted this big time
in check I couldn't I couldn't find one
word nothing
gone whoosh even though my Romanian is
nowhere near as good as my check because
I've been focusing on Romanian my check
was gone now that would not happen to
stronger languages like Japanese even
German
in Russia but for forecheck which was
not yet at that level where it was
solidly anchored I couldn't speak
couldn't speak a word now because I'm
going to the Czech Republic and Slovakia
over Christmas and New Year with my son
and his family to live in England I've
been I'm back on check
well my Romanian is gone I can't say
anything in Romanian I understand I can
read it wouldn't take me a day or two to
get back out of it what I'm trying to
say is that there is real advantage in
focusing very intensively and you can
always revive your languages and I do
this right there you go back to them and
maybe if you were talking to Pella if if
you were to spend you know six months or
a year on Russian which is a full-time
job and then you were to spend six
months on German during that six month
period you might want to spend 20% of
your time just keeping the keeping the
Russian on the back burner simmering
there so you don't fall back too far I
never worry about you know what I might
have forgotten or lost in Korean
Romanian check because I know that in a
day or two I've got back or even less
but on the fly like that bingo today you
say you speak language X go for it I can
do that in most of my languages I can't
do it in Czech Romanian Korean and so
forth so to summarize by all means study
more than one language I wish I mean I
think it's a good thing I think that our
language instruction in our schools
should be more of an exploration
discover more languages and cultures to
language and stuff like that rather than
getting people to speak correctly
obviously where the language is required
for work and and that's typically the
case with English that's not the correct
strategy there you have to focus on and
enabling people to communicate so yeah
multiple languages is good but insofar
as as what I like to do when I study
languages I like to concentrate on one
at a time but that is me and I know
there are other excellent polyglots who
have a different approach
you can probably search the internet on
this subject and find advice that's
different for mine so thank you for
listening and bye for now and let me
know if you have any questions and I do
enjoy getting these kinds of specific
questions I can't promise that I will
always make a video but if I think these
are subjects of interest to a lot of
people I'm very happy to make a video on
that subject okay thank you for
listening bye for now